right mr. hockey okay
Thank You Casper this is joint work with
me hollows and the audience
Bruno loaf and shag Nick Mook about the
so and the slides haven't quite kept up
with the times because Sean Nick is no
longer here he is now a postdoc with me
al and this work was done while he was a
graduate student at the fr okay so this
is what we will see today so let me just
get into the problem so I guess you
already know by now
everything about static data structures
but let me still just go through the
drill so you have a static data
structure problem you are given some
data that you have to store you can
pre-process the data there's no
computational cost associated with
pre-processing and then you are given a
query and then you have to query so this
is the query and then given the query
what you were T what is the cost of
answering this query is the number of
probes that you make on your
pre-processed data structure okay so
this is typically how it goes so it's
very interactive and here you make T
queries what do you want to 80 the
answers and at the end of it you have to
give the correct answer okay so this is
the this is the abstract model that we
are in so we call this an SWT solution
if you can prop you if you can use s
memory cells to store your data after
pre-processing each of your memory cells
contains about the W bits and no matter
what the query is from your query space
the query can be answered by probing T
cells
so the problem that we will be
interested is a class of problems here
called matrix vector product where you
know the the the data will always be a
matrix n by n matrix boolean matrix and
the query will be sometimes just one
vector and sometimes as we will see
maybe two vectors and what you have to
do is to answer sort of queries that
first have to evaluate so you have to
evaluate m times three so the matrix
vector product and then depending on the
problem you have to give an answer based
on what the matrix M times V that
product has evaluated to so here's an
example one might ask how many rows of
this matrix are orthogonal to V which
means that you take the product n times
V and find out how many zeros there are
in the answer so this is called the
orthogonal vector counting problem this
is a quite well known problem it has
been asked in other communities like in
fine grain complexity then for this
problem of course you did the query
vector the query is just corresponding
to one vector now as I said sometimes we
might have two vectors so suppose I have
another vector well then you want to
output a very natural problem you want
all put this vector matrix vector
product like u times M times V this is
one bit and this is called the matrix
sorry vector matrix vector
multiplication problem and today we are
going to be on this you could define
this over any sort of field or any even
the boolean semi-ring but we will just
today look at f2 so all the entries are
0 1 all matrix operations are over f2 so
what are our results these are results
so what we show is that any randomized
data structure will need at least these
many queries so notice that this is not
crossing making any major breakthrough
in the sense that it's not crossing the
well-known barrier of static data
structures because you know you still
get only epsilon n where
and is the size of the query space okay
so this is the best possible kind of
lower bound that you can get short of a
breakthrough but what's interesting is
that for first of all we get this for
two interesting class of problems and
secondly the bounds are average case so
you know even if you want to make slight
advantage over random guessing so so
read this in this way there is there
exists some epsilon says that if you do
not make about epsilon and many queries
then you can't compute the vector matrix
vector with advantage better than two to
the minus R epsilon R so there is some
fixed Epsilon and and the same thing is
here for the orthogonal vector counting
problem
so here I've assumed just to get an
average case bound let's say the the
problem was to count if the number of
orthogonal vectors is 0 0 mod 3 ok so
then you can you know you could by just
giving a constant answer you can get
two-thirds advantage and this is you're
saying that just to beat that naive
probability you will have to expend a
lot of query time so these are the two
results and actually what would be more
interesting for particularly this crowd
is the way we prove this results which
is we are lifting theorem for a certain
communication game which I'll soon come
to so these are just two concrete
results that we get
so first also note that the upper bound
here is for let's say the orthogonal
vector counting problem the the upper
bound is n square by w log s and let me
just quickly sketch sketch that thing
so you have this matrix Evan and cross N
and I'm really just divided into blocks
of size R let's say
so now again this can be divided into
size our number of blocks is n by r and
now you can look at all possible pre
computations linear combinations of
these are columns right for every block
I can pre-compute them so for each one
of them I have 2 to the our linear
combinations possible and each linear
combination is an N bit vector so if I
have W cells I can store them in end by
W number of cells because each cell is
worth W bits and there are such n by r
blocks so this is my space needed right
so log of s is roughly about R plus some
small order terms and the number of
queries that I need to make is now when
I get a vector I know I read this R each
of these blocks and I know you know
corresponding correspondingly here which
linear combination do I need so I will
actually need query about n by r times n
by W right which is n square by W R
which is about n square by W office
that's good so the upper bound is n
square by W log s always because I can
compute the entire matrix vector product
following this thing so if the if if W
is n which is not the typical range that
you look at data structure W is log of n
but you know in some sort of in some
models like the external memory model W
can be large so when W is n this shrinks
to epsilon n by log s and in our lower
bound as well if you put W equals n you
get exactly about n by log s so for
large word size this is this is tight
this can't be improved so let me also
state some related results very quickly
so you know in the in a seminal work
militares and natal melters and Nissan
suffer and weakness and they considered
again a matrix vector product problem
where now you know you given a matrix
which you pre-processors before then
given a vector you want to find out
whether m dot V is exactly equal to 0
which is also a subspace membership
problem and that's why we call it the
spam problem and they were able to show
that for that the number of queries
needed would be n by log s this is the
deterministic lower bound this actually
also works for one-sided error but it
does not work for two-sided error for
good reasons and this this method that
they used which I will come to very soon
called the richness technique does not
seem to quite work for vector matrix
vector product or orthogonal vector
counting so in another very recent work
Kasper and Ryan showed that for the
vector matrix vector product in fact you
can you can solve it quite efficiently
because naively you think that you need
n square but they showed that this can
be done in n to the three-halves over
square root of W and I think later today
we are going to hear more about this
talk by Chakravarthi data
so but however these are over the
boolean semi-ring okay so these don't
these don't work for over f2 which is R
which is R which is what we consider so
it's still conceivable and I think it's
an excellent candidate to show an N
square lower bound when when the word
size is about log log n so n square by
log n lower bound
even for polynomial data structure we
don't have any evidence that such a
lower bound is is not possible so again
these were these are result so how do we
prove this as I said so we prove it we
are a very general technique called
lifting theorems and the the connection
here is through communication complexity
so there is a well known connection that
was initiated in the work of builders
and natal in the first paper showing
that there is a model independently
interesting and also connects two data
structures so if you prove lower bounds
on that asymmetric communication model
that implies lower bound for data
structures and we revisit that model and
we are what we are able to show is the
simulation theorem both for
deterministic and randomized so this is
the new part and this is the I think
interesting the most interesting aspect
of the world so let's quickly go to the
asymmetric model so this is this as I
said we're going to introduce my
militares and natal here unlike in the
in the standard communication model you
are the emphasis is one of the players
is going to have a long or large input
and the other player is going to have a
short input okay and because there's
this asymmetry in the size of inputs you
know there is naturally going to be
budgets that are going to be placed on
how much a player can communicate
because if for example Bob who has a
very small input is allowed to
communicate a lot then Bob can just
transfer all the bits that he has to
Alice and then the game is over so you
have to constrain Bob in a meaningful
way which says that you know Bob is
allowed to send only B bits
Alice is allowed to send a bits because
Alice has a larger input typically
than be and when there is a protocol
that obeys that conforms to this budget
then we say that that's an order Amy
protocol okay and we want to prove a
lower bound well we said that either
Alice has to send a mate's for solving
that problem or bob has to send B bits
and the notation I lose here is that in
such a case I will say that the
complexity of the problem is Omega a B
so there are constants here hiding so
I'm just saying loosely that I'll say
this is Omega a B has Omega a B
complexity so how does this connect two
data structures well the connection is
actually quite indigent and simple so
suppose you had an SWT solution in data
structure the claim is it gives rise to
this efficient protocol in the
asymmetric model so where Alice would
send TW bits and Bob would send T log of
s bits why so so it's just clear from
the from just visualizing what's going
on so now I'm going to use so Alice is
just going to simulate the data
structure and Bob is going to simulate
what the query algorithm will do and so
you know each time Alice sorry Bob
queries Bob is squaring a particular
cell so Bob sends log of s bits and then
gets back W bits which is the contents
of those cells so if this occurs 40
rounds then of course you know in total
Alice sends three W bits and bobs cents
T of T times log of s bits so if you can
prove a lower bound you know on these
things then you get a lower bound
relating TW NS and that's what we are
going to do so what this original paper
did was they introduced a richness
technique which I will
I will get to if there is time and it
was the end of my talk and they proved
results using the richness techniques
for a variety of problems but what we
are going to do today is to prove this
using a using a generic technique which
will which is generic but it will only
work for this sort of matrix vector
product class of problems that player
considering so what would be their
setting so the setting would be of this
composed functions now typically in
block composition of course you have you
know Alice has K inputs x1 through XK
and Bob has Y 1 2 YK and then you have
some gadget G that is applied to each
instance X I Y I and then you compute
some function of applying the gadget but
here on the other hand because of the
asymmetry what we will have is you know
there will be one input just for ball
whereas Alice would get P independent
inputs and then we are going to apply
this gadget where the gadget would be
applied with the same input Y for Bob
but with various different inputs for
Alice and then as before
this would give rise to P bits and we
can apply a function of those pivots so
in particular what we will consider
today it was I mean you could you could
do this for any gadget G but for the for
matrix vector product over F over f2
what we will look at is when G is the
inner product ok then you get exactly F
composed with matrix vector product and
so this is this is what you have because
this is the matrix P rolls and you take
the product and this product is
basically what G is so what we can show
is the following
ok first let me show you an upper bound
so what should we expect so there is a
very naive generic way to to solve
problems of this kind which is why I
using parity decision trees
so claim that for any F you know F of
matrix-vector product can be solved with
where Alice sends the penalty decision
tree complexity of F times M and Bob
just sends the parity decision tree
complexity of f and it's not it's
actually quite quite simple to see why
this is the case is because of the fact
that there is just one y so so Alice is
given X 1 through X P Bob is given Y and
now they want to use a parity disapper
project parity decision tree that exists
for F to solve this problem so they
would just simulate the penalty decision
tree so at each point a priority
decision tree asks a query and the query
it asks about this is on the input which
to F but the input which to F are
generated by taking this matrix vector
product right so it asks a query on
these bits and well you can just view it
differently you can just think of this I
mean the this is like a vector matrix
vector product so you can first evaluate
this and this Alice can do of course by
by herself and when she evaluates this
Prairie she gets an an N so this is 1
Cross P vector so she gets an n-bit
vector so she does [ __ ] she can evaluate
the query on her side and then just
transfer the result which is an N bit
vector to Bob and then Bob computes the
inner product with Y and sends back the
answer so each query in the decision
tree apparently decision tree that you
have can be simulated by Alice doing the
corresponding bitwise XOR of her matrix
ok and then transferring the result to
Bob and then Bob giving back the answer
ok so then in total there for alice is
going to use and they do this for each
query traversing down the parity
decision tree so for each query
therefore in total therefore alice
communicates the parity decision tree
complexity of f times
and and Bob just communicates parity
decision tree complexity away
okay so so this is the a very natural
upper bound and what we show is that
this is the best that they can do in
general meaning that either Alice in any
protocol for for this game either Alice
will have to communicate these many bits
exactly matching what the upper bound is
or Bob will have to communicate that
many bits so and this will this also
actually turns out to be true for the
for the randomized model so we can not
only prove a deterministic simulation
theorem but this the same proof with a
bit more work extends to the randomized
model as well so what's the main
ingredient of our argument so the main
ingredient is as in you know in various
works in lifting theorem what we what we
do is given a protocol which is of this
form where Alice sends at most C times
and bits and bobs and C bits you know we
can take this protocol and extract
extract the parity decision tree for F
with about cost 100 times C okay so if
both if I knew that Alice sent C times n
and Bob sent C then I can extract a
parent a decision tree for F of cost at
most hundred times C and therefore if
the parity decision tree complexity of F
was large then these things should be
large okay so this is this follows the
same template in this sense as the other
lifting theorems but of course the the
difficulty here is somehow parity
decision tree has to enter in my lifting
result right because I can't hope to get
a normal decision tree lower bound okay
so that's that's that's the the main
sort of mysterious thing the other thing
is of course you know there are this
somehow to consider also that Alice and
Bob have got different budgets and Bob
has more importantly bob has just got
one input
so I wouldn't have time to get into this
the proof of the lifting theorem but in
all this lifting theorems you sort of
maintain an invariant right you want to
say that okay you're going down the
protocol tree and at each point you
maintain a rich rectangular region of
rectangle that sort of allows you to
query minimally and and whenever you
don't query when you stop you can still
say that the things that have unquiet
they all have sort of a representative
in the rectangle that you have
maintained right this is what bias I
mean you have to choose your richness
measure appropriately so that you can
make this argument happen so usually
what has been done in lifting theorems
for example the the BPP lifting theorem
of goofs potassium Watson recently is
that you know they look at the minimum
the block wise minimum entropy should be
large so here you know the rows are 0 1
to the N P so this is these are all
matrices of the type P cross M and Bob
has an N bit vector so you might think
that you know can we apply a similar
technique here would this measure
suffice and well first of all that I
mean as I said somewhere the parity
decision tree has to enter and you know
these things these measures naturally
work when you are trying to simulate an
ordinary decision tree so this doesn't
work but a very natural adaptation of
this works which is that instead of
looking at minimum entropy block wise I
look at a linear linear mean entropy so
what is linear mean entropy and this is
the the the the novelty in the work so
the linear mean entropy is the following
so consider so now I have to look at
somehow I have to look at affine
subspace s so consider the affine space
of all possible entries here such that
if Q is a query vector
you know Q multiplied by this those
matrices give me the vector U ok so this
is the set of all matrices
that Q times though that matrix is equal
to this vector you okay this is this is
the affine space that I'm looking at
okay so some I have some a subset of
this and then I said the linear min
entropy of this is the largest ETA such
that if I look at any extension of Q Q
prime which are still so these are a
fresh set of queries but they are still
linearly independent of U then if I look
at Q prime dot X so X is a possible P
cross n matrix okay so if things were
perfect then this would be completely
random right sure so Q is my query
vector
so these q q is the set of queries that
I've made so far okay and I'm some and
somehow I've been constrained to fix
them to something you know I'm looking
at a fresh set of queries Q prime which
I have not made and I want to be sort of
rich with respect to this Q Prime like
the parity decisions in or parity
decision tree query
so you're going down that it's a very
difficult Victor yeah so Q is up use a
bunch of vectors subspace this form so
maybe you've made our queries so it's a
it's a it's an R cross P matrix each
each query is like a it's a pivot vector
so is a set of is the current set of
sorry matrices that satisfy the
following property you know when you
apply this Q on a you get this fixed
vector U so I mean so Q is just like in
ordinary decision trees you query a
particular coordinate Q corresponds to a
linear coordinate okay and you queried
it and you want an answer right so that
the set of possible answers that you've
got is you okay so these are the set of
matrices which when queried by Q will
conform to the set of answers that
you've seen you are maintaining that
right you the vector
few times so for every X in a few times
X is equal to you it is a set of
matrices all I'm saying is for all X in
a few times X is equal to U and U is in
0 1 to the R so a is a set of vectors no
he is a set of matrices then how it can
be equal to e you if you multiplied by a
matrix I mean so he's matrix yeah yeah
so you multiply matrix by matrix and you
get a vector I think this funny
did you see how about the matrix of a
vector I think it's just I think it's
right because you're just you're just
getting
the subsidies the subset of the Subspace
right so you're right so you're sorry
you you either making you you is a
matrix I'm sorry used
the next question and how we use a in
the definition of the entropy so this is
what I'm saying so if you choose X X is
sort of chosen uniformly at random from
a okay so the condition is if I look at
every Q Prime which extends you in a
linearly independent way so so Q prime
is another set of queries each of which
is linearly independent from Q right and
if you look at when when X is chosen
uniformly random from a and you look at
Q prime dot X yeah that's going to give
you Q prime times n bits right because
you're looking at Q prime Q prime dot X
now if you look at this distribution the
minimum I mean the largest million
repeat could have had is without the
Zita right Q prime time sir and I'm
saying that you should have at least ETA
the largest theta such that you have ETA
times Q prime time
so and this should so this is the exact
this is sort of the linear analogue of
of block mini entropy right so each Q
Prime sort of defines a block in the
linear after a linear transformation and
I'm saying that corresponding to that
linear block the mean entropy has to be
large this has to be true for every
block which is linearly independent of
the set of queries that you have seen so
far
so okay so so this is the invariant that
we maintain but that's on this side okay
but for the other side which is the
smaller side we actually turns out that
that side is simpler to maintain so all
we need is largeness so for on Bob side
what we need to maintain is just that
the main entropy has to be large which
is which is a which is a bit different
from the usual lifting theorem where you
know you sort of maintain this careful
block block mini entropy with respect to
the smaller side so okay so and let me
just quickly go through so I wouldn't
have time to talk about the lifting
theorem more but let me just give you an
example why this sort of thing can be
more powerful than the richness method
so the richness method just to quickly
recap it sort of says the following that
if your matrix is sort is UV rich which
means that you know your original
function had this property that there
exists some set of V columns in which
the each of these columns there were at
least u many ones then you call that
such a matrix UV rich and you
essentially prove that in an a B
protocol if your matrix to start with
was you be rich then you will have a
large rectangle of this kind and if
you're if you didn't have a rectangle of
that kind that would just show that the
there is no AV protocol but the the
important point here is that you know
this this this method is so is sort of a
bit too powerful in the sense that it
ends up proving not only deterministic
lower bound but it also proves
randomized one-sided lower bound
okay and here's a function which which
will have large deterministic complexity
but not randomized complexity and
therefore because of the because of the
fact that I said before richness cannot
be used as it is to prove this bound so
the the function that we look at is a
promised function where you know you you
have two n bits and in for the inputs on
which the function evaluates to 1 it is
promised that on all odd indices you
have 0 and on the even indices you have
at least n by 10 ones and for inputs
which are on which a function evaluates
to 0 or the the even indices have all
zeros but on the audit indices you have
at least n by 10 ones and now this
function has a very simple 0 error
parity decision tree complexity because
at random a parity decision tree would
in fact just not even a parody decision
tree an ordinary decision tree
complexity because at random if you if
you sample two consecutive integers in
this as one odd and one even then you're
either going to with high probability c1
1 0 or 0 1 right and seeing either of
which you know what what the promise to
input was so it's easy to just by two
queries to separate the two promised set
of inputs so it has a it has a small 0
error query complexity and therefore you
know the if you lift it with this matrix
vector product the that thing will have
a small 0 error protocol of cost order n
order 1 right because for each query you
have to send n bits to Bob so that's why
you get an order 1 and Bob sends back
the small answer one bit answer and
therefore richness would fail to give
you anything better than that because
richness ends up proving lower bounds
also for as I said for one side a terror
however what we can show is that this
even this with this promise the
deterministic parity decision tree
complexity of this function is large its
maximally large you will need n queries
and therefore by using our lifting
theorem we can show that this function
would have deterministic
lower amount of Omega n square so Alice
either Alice has to send Omega n square
bits or Bob has to send Omega n bits and
this sort of maximally separates it's
from richness
[Applause]
[Music]
oh the for a further four data structure
well I mean using this communication
complexity approach we cannot go beyond
the log of the query space right because
that was that your question
we'll knock through this method I just
meant that it is it is it is plausible
that that is the true bound because this
still uses communication complexity it
won't be able to go beyond
no Joe it makes a lot of sense
can you please go to the definition of
this enthalpy
so
here is if there is some set of quail is
not necessarily mean out subset of and
the decision tree will be consist with
the consist of this well okay so not you
know just abstract and you replace it
from instead of Q prime fvq Brandon does
not logically follow from jQuery so far
in the same property
so you're redefining that or
we can talk offline somewhere in the
proof we use linearity further
more than one place actually
so in this proof you didn't use that
whatever Alice answers it's like memory
less it only depends on would like
indeed a structure lower bound indeed a
structural model Ellison ceremony depend
on what box ends in the last strong
sorry that that's the bottleneck of
using this communication model that's
true so are there any communication what
is that even try to formalize them
watching has had some model that sounded
like somehow somehow you have to yeah
what you're saying is that alice is
cannot be an active player Alice has to
be you have to move have a game in which
Alice is very passive right and that is
yeah well you seem like there is a clean
model to capture they're the cleanest
model is pro possibly the cell pro model
itself
oh I think I'll be there again
[Applause]
[Music]